all right we are here to talk about Rafe
Jordan you've been playing a lot of race
well she is my main character for many
reason she's kind of a complex character
to get a handle on she's kind of a bit
more of a skirmisher so if you're kind
of new to first-person shooters maybe
she's not the first pick for you maybe
you go someone like Bangalow or
something like that and said but once
you do have a handle on apexis controls
and how wraith works you can use her
abilities to really bamboozle other
opponents and do a lot of really
advanced hit-and-run tactics well why
don't we start with into the void into
the void Azure tactical skill and it
allows her to reposition yourself
quickly through the safety of void space
what are some tactics with that so
probably my most used tactic for it is
just to get out of Dodge like if she's
being shot at being sniped out of
grenades incoming I'll just use into the
void to reposition myself yeah away from
the danger behind cover somewhere else
because even if she's not completely
invisible while she's using this ability
she is invulnerable all three seconds of
invulnerability exactly so I will admit
that there is a bit of a problem with
into the void if you do use it other
enemy wraiths can follow you into the
void and easily follow you you're all in
the same void space it can also be
easily countered by other enemies just
around you if you happen to be in an
enclosed space because as wraiths into
the void you can only clamor over
objects you can't go through them so if
you're in a building and everyone shuts
all the doors and windows you can't get
out and enemies can easily then just
figure out where you are so they can see
the little blue line that you're leaving
behind us you're trying to get away
that's happened to me on way too many
occasions and you also mentioned pay
attention to the shadows what do you
mean by that so you'll notice that when
wraith dives into the void there's these
weird black outlines in the void space
and those are basically other wraiths
from like other dimensions and times so
if you go towards any of those shadows
that's basically marking where you're
going to exit the void space if you see
one off to your right and maybe another
one kind of in front of you it's
basically saying if you turn to the
right right now this is where you're
going to exit the void space but if you
continue forward
you're going you're gonna come out of
the void space over here which is a nice
way of keeping track of how much time
you have left if you don't want to just
count off three seconds near it let's
move on to her passive voices from the
void this is basically like raves
spidey-sense
a voice warns her when she's being aimed
out and she's surrounded if there's a
trap anything like that and then from
there you can press down on the d-pad if
you're playing on console and you can
warn teammates exactly it's definitely
ability that is kind of selfish in the
event that you hear about it first it
doesn't alert all of your teammates is
up to you to be the better person and
let your teammates know that there's
danger approaching which you absolutely
should because this is a very powerful
ability especially when it's getting
really close and it's the very small
circle and an enemy could be around any
quarter it's ideal for dealing with
snipers because she'll get a warning
whether she's being pinged or she's in a
sniper scope but you can just pop into
the void as soon as the shots coming at
her or if you're in the close quarters
fight and you know there's a caustic or
something like that around she'll warn
you of any traps or if someone's
sneaking up on you because it amplifies
footsteps
so ideally wear headphones because the
whispers and the footsteps are very very
quiet and they'll typically sound before
you get the button prompt so wearing
headphones gives you just a tiny like
half second like head start and then
finally her ultimate skill dimensional
rift and this basically allows her to
place two portals and you can travel
between those portals but it's not
instantaneous you do travel between but
you're invincible as you travel from one
to the other
yeah exactly and you only have 60
seconds to use it as many times as you
want and I've seen a lot of people use
this as a support getting a downed
teammate from a dangerous firefight to
someplace behind cover or even just
getting into the circle quicker yeah
exactly your team where they need to be
quick but I instead prefer to use it in
a more offensive approach to bamboozle
people since people are beginning to
realize now that enemies can go through
wraiths portals a lot of people now try
to chase enemy teams who try to escape
the Wraiths portal so I'll try to trick
people and put one portal like over an
edge or in a spot where I know the zone
is going to be sometime hoping that an
enemy foolishly decides to just dive
into a wraith portal before even
checking to see if anyone went into it
first and sometimes they fall to their
death
sometimes they land somewhere outside
the zone and if none of those things are
close enough or available have a cost to
go down a trap have someone a thermite
grenades at the ready something anything
waiting on the other side of the portal
to just basically pepper whoever decides
to foolishly just step through thinking
that they're going to get an easy kill
and that's a good way to transition into
her weaknesses caustic can do a lot of
damage to her oh yeah I've I've had a
couple times where I've placed two
portals down and I go through it then I
go back through it and I come back
through and there's a caustic trap
waiting for me and then I'm slowed I'm
taking damage and they just picked me
off really easily ever say caustic will
do it bangalore can smoke you as soon as
you go
that portal and that's just the worst
but because wraith has such a tiny
hitbox if she goes through the portals
like behind another person much larger
say like gibraltar it's much harder to
hit her because her hitbox for whatever
reason is just so much smaller than
almost every other character in the game
and that's it for a rape guide if
there's anything we missed or you guys
have any strategies make sure to leave
them in the comments below and stay
tuned to game spot because we have more
of these guides on the way